okay now the other accomplishment that
your office inside the white house has
largely been
credited with is criminal justice reform
and i was wondering if you could sort of
lay out the details there because i've
been
more critical of criminal justice reform
i'm a very uh tough on-crime
right-winger
which means that my belief is that i've
seen it in california letting people out
of jail early
on the in the hopes that they are not
going to be recidivis has largely
redounded
uh to the negative in the state of
california but what does criminal
justice reform do and what doesn't it do
so uh you're being a right-wing you know
tough on crime is
is very much in line with my boss
president trump and he feels the strange
way i mean he's very strong on law and
order and doing it now
in politics you know a term like
criminal justice reform again there's
about a thousand shades of gray and
there's
a lot of different definitions for what
it can mean and any
um any policy or any element you know
taken to an extreme could be bad and
and you know even things that are good
and so the criminal justice reform that
we put in place is not about you know
letting
uh you know murders and rapists out of
prison like some of the opponents tried
to criticize it and it's not
like what they did in new york which was
the no cash bail which went way too far
which made the streets less safe the
whole notion of what we did was
we brought law enforcement together
along with the the advocates community
and we said
what can we do to reduce crime and what
we did is we followed the models that
they did in a lot of republican states
like georgia and texas and kentucky
where what they did is they took the
prisons and they basically said we have
a lot of people in these prisons
who have a high likelihood just for the
data of going on to commit future crimes
so in any business if you know where
your future customers are coming from
that's where you want to market to and
then you know as a country we have been
having this philosophical debate over
the last years which is what's the
purpose of our prisons is it to
you know punish people is it to
warehouse people or is it to
rehabilitate people
so it does cost the taxpayers a lot of
money every year to house people in
prison and then in addition to that
if they're all going to get out anyway
so or most of them i think 96 97 percent
of people are going to leave so
you know when they leave the question is
what product are you sending back into
your communities so if while you have
them in your custody
you can give them skills training and
you can help them you know deal with
whatever substance abuse issues they
have or mental issues and help them get
the help they need and then help them
transition back into the community then
what you're doing is you're reducing
costs by not having them come back
you're also reducing future crime by
getting them back into a job so
the criminal justice reform that we did
brought programs that were very
successful that helped people re-enter
society
to the federal level and then what we
saw was 13 states copied that
and i think that by and large has been a
very successful program there are some
things that come under the quote-unquote
uh title of criminal justice reform
that this administration has not pushed
for so we're not supportive of every
element of it but
when things are common sense that can
both help people live better lives you
know we do believe in second chances
america is a country of second chance we
don't want to
judge people by their their their their
worst mistake they've ever made
you know people have the right for
redemption uh but we also want to keep
communities safe and
you know for me this was a very personal
one that i probably wouldn't have
understood you know my father
uh went to prison for a year and i went
and visited him every
week and it was something that uh i met
a lot of people who were in prison and
what i found was there were some people
who were just bad people
you know for whatever reason they had
rough childhoods or rough experiences
but there are also a lot of people in
prison
who are good people who made a mistake
and then they you know dug themselves
into a hole and then they just you know
to try to get out did worse and worse
things to dig themselves out and
and then there were some people who you
know made a mistake and they really
wanted to turn around their lives so
you know just because these people are
there does this mean that you know the
society should turn their back on them
they're americans they're human beings
and
and the right thing to do is to try to
help them find their way and so you know
when i was in the private sector we had
a second chance program in our company
where we took people out of rikers we
gave them mentorship and training and
helped teach them skills
and they became some of our most
phenomenal employees in the company so
i do believe that you know we have a
responsibility in society to
you know help everyone and to do a
difference and this is one of the
policies that's been
very successful in keeping our community
safe but also
uh you know you know being kind to the
people who who need kindness the most
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content